[Musique]
on va continuer en france est ce que ce
serait un peu ridicule sinon on connaît
pas grand-chose à tête ni hautaine x de
prendre une tête
non moi non plus voilà on a été invité
deux fois à participer à celle de
martini et on allait trouver des bonnes
excuses
ce soir on n'a pas trouvé donc s'il l'a
regardé voies de l'axé du coup l'année
prochaine voire se retaper la même chose
chez les valaisans oui on va improviser
un petit peu voilà on a le timing on a
l'habitude des timings aussi puisqu'on a
tout
toutes les semaines 26 minutes voire
parfois un peu plus pour raconter
l'actualité
on va d'abord parce qu'on a fait un
petit plan voilà ni qu'elle s'attaque
voilà on va commencer par se présenter
oui bon je vous présente vincent peillon
vincent riou à 31 ans depuis hier il est
chablaisiens ou sablé zandi les deux
chapeaux les deux sont acceptés mais
voilà les deux sont acceptés il a une
formation de
l'école cantonale d'art de lausanne est
il à ce que je voulais dire d'autre qui
commençait à faire de la radio ce jury
le chablais radio chablais son origine
de l'origine de son premier contact avec
les médias et aujourd'hui donc il
travaille pour une émission qui
s'appelle 26 minutes
vincent kucholl ici présent est né un 23
décembre
non pas 23 avril il a aujourd'hui 40 et
40 41 ans
oui oui puisqu'on a dix ans de
différence est juste enfin ce qui choque
et du nord vaudois quoi c'est bien c'est
l'expérience et la jeunesse un joli
mélange
il est né dans le nord vaudois à yverdon
plus précisément il a fait ses études
chaignat moudon oui oui mais c'est pour
moi tu sais en tant que chablaisiens
d'excès un peu au dessus de le 27 dans
vos doigts
donc il est né à yverdon mais a grandi
année à moutons mais a grandi à yverdon
puis il a fait des études de sciences
politiques à lausanne
et puis parallèlement à ça il a ensuite
fait d une formation de théâtre de
comédien à l'école serge martin de
genève voilà donc un roman comme ça plus
régionaliste dans sa formation
voilà on est là parce qu'on fait on des
invités de venir parler de nous voilà au
nombrilisme et c'est ce qu'on nous a
demandé de faire
on fait donc l'émission qui s'appelle 26
minutes vous connaissez une émission qui
décortiquent l'actualité avec un regard
décalé et caustique alors le truchement
de l'humour voilà une émission qu'on
fait depuis maintenant deux ans et demi
on en est à la 70
7 6 ou 7 6 ou 7ème on sera la 100e 11
décembre une émission qui nous prend
tout notre temps ça notre métier on nous
demande souvent ce qu'on fait à côté
parce que les gens s'imaginent que 26
minutes bah ouais vous bossez une demi
heure par semaine
donc ça nous prend à peu près tout notre
temps on est on est les deux là dessus à
plein depuis janvier 2015
et cette émission est diffusée tous les
samedis donc sur rts et depuis très peu
de temps sur d'autres canaux
oui depuis samedi prochain sur la srf
aussi donc c'est l'émission ça va enfin
qu'une émission comme on rigolait est
exportée chez les bourbes in april
expérience en fait on a fait ils nous
ont proposé de faire une émission
spéciale allemands suisses allemands
suisses alémaniques donc on a fait une
mission en allemand ce coup une langue
colombes
pas pratique et qu'on ne parle
absolument pas avec vincent donc c'est
intéressant derrière c'est nous on dit
bell continue et fait non plus le talent
à oak et non des avants prend les
francophones des françaises mais l'ailé
romande et en les dotant les sous titres
donc ils vont se planter la gueule
vraisemblablement voilà mais voilà ils
font toujours tout pour les suisses
allemands on le sait comment on en est
arrivé à ce projet 26 minutes racontant
un petit peu dallas la genèse de cette
émission qui a maintenant deux ans et
demi le temps passe très vite beaucoup
plus vite que ce qu'on avait prévu donc
on va le prendre je n'ai pas lu comment
est né ce projet mais ils rencontrent au
paléo en festival paléo en 2009 j'étais
fraîchement arrivé à couleur 3 et
vincent il travaillait depuis quelques
années il faisait des chroniques déjà
humoristique et déjà un peu décalé par
le truchement de l'humour un regard sur
la société etc
on s'est rencontré à paléo on s'est bien
entendu on s'est dit on c'est bourré la
gueule on s'est dit tiens c'est aime
bien faire quoi toi j'aime bien bossé
périr nadia ben tiens moi aussi on s'est
dit on pourrait faire ça ensemble et on
a fait ça ensemble on va commencer par
faire ça en fin d'année on est allé à
sydney pour une opération pour que la
rts puisse dépenser l'argent de billag
prélevée depuis fribourg pour encore
quelque temps
on est donc allé claqué ce fric à sydney
pendant une semaine on a fait une
antenne délocalisée de couleur 3 c'était
couleurs très on a fait un petit journal
de bord d'un auditeur fictifs qui
accompagnait l'équipe
il s'appelait monsieur cholet et c'est
la première collaboration qu'on a qu'on
a qu'on a eu les deux bon ça c'est bien
marché on va notre grande surprise et du
coup on se dit bon on continue et à la
grande surprise aussi des patrons de la
chaîne qui nous ont dit mais non mais en
fait la radio enfin donc vous avez deux
semaines sur place ou une semaine et
demie vous prenez juste un jour pour
faire vos conneries et puis après vous
bossez pour de vrai pour la radio parce
qu'on n'est pas là pour ça de la vidéo
[Musique]
deuxième chapitre c'est les matinales de
couleur 3 j'ai eu la chance de reprendre
la production de cette tranche la un peu
plus tard deux ans plus tard en fait en
2011 1er avril 2011 voilà et puis deux
trois mois plus tard bien commencé 120
secondes en vidéo voilà c'est ça
exactement puisque vincent déjà cette
chronique depuis quelques années avec
l'ancien animateur de la matinale yann
zitouni par téléphone tous les matins à
poil ou admis à poil dans sa cuisine
et bah du coup avec mon bagage de visu
d'intérêt pour le pôle image et pour
tout ce qui est visuel en gros je me
suis dit bastien est ce qu'on n'en ferai
pas une capsule le pareil mais sur place
dans les studios en direct la plupart du
temps et avec des invités donc pareil
qu'avant par téléphone mais les invités
qui sont la grille mêlant le studio dans
studio et vient aussi du fait qu'on a
découvert sur internet des chroniques
qui était que radio ouï que sonore et
qui avaient été pompés par des
internautes des auditeurs et qui les
avait mis sur youtube avec une image
figée et on est tombé dessus il y avait
150 mille vue envahirait la voix c'était
juste 150 mais l'écouté on se dit mais
en fait ce serait un peu con que ce soit
ça se reproduise trop souvent il faut
que ce soit nous qui mettons ça sur
internet et c'est ce qu'on a fait
toujours en se disant aimer c'est cool
c'est ensemble continuent à boire des
verres et à créer des trucs donc on a
continué durant 3 3 saisons à faire
cette matinale et puis parallèlement à
ça comme on faisait aussi un peu
d'improvisation il n'en fait toujours
ensemble via une troupe d'improvisation
qui s'appelle havre ac à vabre a concédé
bastien pourquoi ce qu'on créerait pas
un spectacle en spectacle sur la base de
ce sont vingt secondes quotidiens qui
servent les 120 secondes présente la
suisse et qu'on a tourné pendant un an
et demi jusqu'en décembre 2014 et en
janvier 2015
on a commencé on s'est dit on s'est dit
on arrête 120 secondes selon trois ans
c'est ainsi que ça suffit on va
s'emmerder si on continue trop longtemps
être crevé en voix de tête
non non non mariable et puis ils se
marient à 6 jours et s'était passé jours
on voit que tu ne t'intéresses pourquoi
ma vie mais c'était il ya six jours
maintenant il ya dix jours mais c'est
elle rigole famille dimanche lundi
quatre jours non on est mardi à 5 jours
belle fille donc voilà pouvait avoir des
gueules un peu variable sur les deux on
s'est dit on arrête la matinale et on a
commencé on a proposé à la rts1 c'était
un peu de rencontres ils nous ont un
petit peu faire un appel du pied je
crois je sais plus très bien bref on a
proposé ce format 26 minutes qui est un
peu la même chose qu'on faisait avant
développer quoi voilà en fait c'est ça
on a on parle d'expérience tout ça de de
regard sur la société depuis qu'on a
commencé cette aventure on a notre objet
notre atelier qui qui prend de plus en
plus d'ampleur qui se développent et ça
c'est une chance même si on continue
aujourd'hui à monza
voilà a continué de manière artisanale
on a eu la chance de développer cet
outil de moins en moins pourquoi je
bosse parce qu'on passe avec une petite
équipe artisanale en est on est en fait
autonome et indépendant de la rts1 on
vend en fait les contenus de l'émission
la rts vient tous les vendredis dans une
boîte de nuit qui s'appelle le chaudron
18 à lausanne ils viennent avec des
caméras qui filment les missions et puis
la diffuse après le samedi 24 heures
après la captation et nous ont fourni
tous les contenus et on le fait de
manière totalement libre c'est à dire
que il découvre en général que on a
pensé fabriqué ben quand ça passe à
l'antenne il ya une personne qui fait
kaki 1 répondant pour la pour
l'entreprise mais c'est une seule
personne et puis là on a un très bon
rapport de confiance s'est jamais arrivé
qu'on soit censuré on se fait taper sur
les doigts une fois pour un détail nous
on avait titre autres marques dans un
sketch sur la pas censé le faire
en l'occurrence ont incité le sponsor de
l'émission je pense 50 fois
andros est il apparaît très près partout
dans un cri aux invalides j'aime souvent
douala et dans james bond ya la marque
heineken qui est souvent invisible et
marque en fait ouais était le partenaire
du dernier épisode
et puis on s'est dit on fait pareil avec
une autre boisson sort endroit pions ils
ont violé là elle va rendre cet avis
look c'est une des réponses évasives et
de taper sur les doigts donc cette
liberté est bien se mérite
cherry et donc la confiance qui nous qui
nous témoignent nous oblige donc on fait
tout ce qu'on peut pour être le plus
pour les plus loin possible sans parce
qu'on pose souvent la question est ce
qu'il ya des limites est ce que vous
vous censurez est ce que vous êtes
censuré et donc on se fait rare qu'on se
dise al assaf n'en fais pas ça arrive de
temps en temps parce que c'est de
mauvais goût ou alors ou alors ça
pourrait être mal compris blessant donc
on a
un jalon un peu enfin le bon goût et le
moral et on se dit c'est comme si on a
la chance d'être 2 et de collaborer donc
ce soit pour l'écriture des sketches ou
à la limite qu'on pourrait franchir on
est tout le temps là serait déjà de
savoir c'est que c'est drôle
est-ce que ce sketch ça a du sens ça a
du sens on peut s'auto checker déjà
ensemble et c'est assez rigolo dans la
dent quand on observe l'évolution de de
notre duo c'est que depuis les matinées
sombre dans le studio de couleur3 être
un peu que les deux c'était pareil à
couleur 3 11 et un peu ce qu'on voulait
on a su garder cette indépendance
éditoriale est et cette confiance des
chefs pour pouvoir faire pareil
aujourd'hui à plus grande échelle ça
c'est assez cool et on a pu s'entourer
de gens d'ailleurs on n'est pas que les
deux on est on est cette personne a
bossé sur l'émission durant la semaine
parce que oui ça prend du temps du des
ressources sur un tournage
j'en ai entre avec les comédiens et
l'équipe de réalisation on est entre 4
et 30 ou 40 on a vous avez été 40 pour
un fait on prépare une parodie de game
of thrones pour le 10 juin ça va
s'appeler game of thrones
oui et le d'ailleurs le personnage de
khal drogo beaux et musclés se trouve
dans cette salle il est juste la photo
moi je fais le nord est
et donc cette série c'est à grand budget
comme vous le savez donc qu'il y avait
beaucoup de figurants sur une scène et
puis à des séquences qui sont plus
simples à tournai où il ya moins de
monde mais on est en général 7,7 des
équipes assez réduite
ça paraît beaucoup cinq ou six personnes
moi je viens de tourner une série pour
la rts il n'y avait jamais moins de 30
personnes sur le plateau
donc c'est vraiment léger par rapport à
ce qui se fait en télévision
habituellement mais donc ça représente
quand même des ressources si on a la
chance d'être entouré d'une équipe assez
jeune ça c'est particulier je suis plus
vieux de la boîte
ça me fait un peu bizarre mais elle en a
deux jeunes de 20 ans qu'ils sont là les
rebonds alleyrat comme des stagiaires
ils sont super cause auront fini on les
engage c'est sûr
donc on découvre 7 7 7 pinière de deux
jeunes qui sont hyper au fait de tout
c'est ce qui à l'image de ce qu'est
narration vidéo et c'est vachement
vachement cool moi c'est avec ces jeunes
on entend le public un petit peu on part
du public
donc les gens on a la chance de faire ce
qu'on fait mais surtout parce que le
public est là et réponses et nous
celui-là il était un petit peu communaux
communautariste non sur couleur 3
c'était une petite niche un peu lassé
grosse niche mais quand même c'était les
gens qui nous suivaient sur l'a3 mais
aussi qu'ils écoutaient pas là trois qui
nous regardaient sur internet et
maintenant avec la télévision depuis le
début 2015 sas et énergie beaucoup ça
s'est élargie si ça marche assez bien la
rtc comptons donc ça aussi ça qui fait
qu'on nous foute la paix parce que ça
marche bien et qu'on n'a pas de plainte
on n'a jamais eu de plainte personne ne
sait jamais en effet s'il ya des fois
des gens qui gueulent fort quand on tue
des chats par exemple c'est le dessus
j'en fais semblant de tuer des chaouis
quand on fait semblant de tous les chats
et des chiens là c'est là on est on est
sous une avalanche de réactions de
mémère à caniche je dis ça parce que
toutes les
et tous les commentaires 90% des
commentaires outrés qui étaient postés
sous le sketch en question il n'avait
pas à 150,60 ces commentaires étaient
produits par des photos de profil avec
une joie de chats de chiens ou une nana
avec deux chats ou de chiens
c'est à dire ma mère à cagnes échoua
chacha qu'il avait qui voit on rit pas
avec les animaux en revanche quand on
parle de la ddt du conflit
israélo-palestinien dépouille du sida
tout ça c'est nickel c'est ok mais sinon
c'est vrai que deux avec l'expérience
cette émission nous permet à nous et on
a énormément de chance de pouvoir
rentrer dans plein d'univers différents
que ce soit chez des bourgeois des
banquiers bourgeois genevois jusqu'à des
quoi d'autre que sa note et l'été les
transports publics là c'est là un truc
con con qu'on observe c'est l'auto
dérision et l'absence de prise au
sérieux des gens dans notre pays c'est
plutôt un bon signal
les gens mais c'est vrai que ce soit les
régions les classes sociales les
professions quand on se moque d'eux tous
ces groupes
ça passe toujours assez bien à ce qu'on
en a un que je n'ai jamais eu de plainte
mon âge très rarement des gens qui
maillent par exemple les profs on est on
y va assez fort sur eux ils songent à
rennes c'est des principaux amateurs des
sketches qu'on fait sur les profits
trouve ça super et 10 passes excellent
je connais encore exactement ça mieux
ils sont pas comme ça et donc ça ça fait
qu'il ya un espèce de sympathie hyper
cool et qui nous ouvre des portes
l'exemple de l'armée assez chouette on a
fait un sketch à l'armée on avait que ça
c'était pour le spectacle
à le porter la conduite de paie chaque
fois ces longues années cool and coup
d'anecdotes de toi le portrait du
colonel dîner du duo kool and the need
on est en contact avec un type de
l'armée qui veut dire mais il faudrait
aller tourner ça dans une place d'armes
ça serait bien dire bah ouais super on
n'a pas droit non allez c'est bon c'est
bon j'organise bio 10 may be du il faut
l'air bürki on a dit ouais mais c'est
loin donc on va plutôt aller à moudon ou
chamblon on voit bien ce plus près de
chez nous mais on va en hélicoptère ils
sont venus nous chercher avec 1
un heureux comme d'un 9 c 135 g plus le
modèle exactement six places en est tous
allés à bure depuis la blécherette et de
décollage le pilote communique avec la
tour ça se fait en anglais genre
lausanne
tout ceci me what the funk bur d'après
la tour de contrôle qui répond amusez
vous bien les gars voient là et on a
volé pendant 45 minutes aller et retour
et à bureaux nous a prêté un piranha une
compagnie donc 150 gars qu'on fait ce
qu'on voulait ll pouvoir aussi on a des
contacts aussi parce qu'on invite
plusieurs personnes d'ailleurs mathieu
fleury qui est ici présent est venu
aussi une façon plateau de 26 minutes
parce qu' on peut venir à la tête des
kz2 fait voilà c'est ça c'est les
échelons nous celle du networking tout
ça c'est vrai que on a de la chance
aussi de s'approcher du pouvoir ça donne
aussi un une saveur assez cool à notre
petite suisse de se dire qu'on peut tous
être en contact et qu'on ait finalement
pas tous dans l'est des castes hyper pas
hétérogènes on a aussi pu tourner une
voiture de flics on a pu avoir un bus t
elle avec une remorque pendant une
journée entière on aller où on voulait
dans lausanne c'était génial avec des
figurants dedans quels élus ciney le
quai stop on veut on peut faire
demi-tour ouais je veux juste au rond
point et des il enlève les les la ligne
dans la
la perche tournepiche c'est un vieux bus
6 tours ni rien de ça c'était dingue
quoi on peut aller dans les chalets de
luxe en station survolé servent enfin au
fur des trucs on se dit très souvent
avec vincent cassel chaque semaine
chaque semaine
parfois on entrerait dans le stress la
peur dit c'est comme bizarre ce job et
ça c'est cool mais peut-être qu'on va
pas faire ça toute notre vie on on parle
de l'avenir on a une minute 50 pour ça
on vous dit qu'on vous êtes on avait
fait trois ans de 120 secondes alors là
on vous continue 26 minutes jusqu'à noël
ce sera la 100e
fin décembre on sait pas si on continue
au delà on a le contrat nous nous
contraint à livrer des missions jusqu'à
noël et des récents sait pas on a des
envies
on a envie de retourner sur scène on a
envie peut-être de faire d'autres forums
d'explorer d'autres formats en images
tout à fait et c'est vrai qu'on parle du
cycle de la matinale qui a duré trois
ans au delà duquel on se dit bon allez
viens on fait autre chose c'est possible
qu'au bout de la 100e de 26 800 iso si
bastien ne qu'on ne commençons pas à
ronronner
remettons-nous en danger et
avançons on verra ça quoi qu'il en soit
c'est donc ensemble on a chassé le thème
et on se disait l'autre jour que on
souhaitait à tout le monde de trouver
son alter ego professionnelle et amicale
et tout ça est parti d'une beuverie à
paléo et puis trouver des connexions où
on arrive à se mettre sur la même ligne
pour défendre les mêmes types de projets
en étant hockey idéologiquement
peut-être plus tôt moralement mais
quoique idéologiquement aussi même
vision du monde qui nous nourrit et qui
nous fait avancer avec plaisir et avec
avec avec une certaine forme de fierté
tout à fait c'est assez ça c'est beau et
agréable et pour la petite anecdote des
25 dernières secondes
on s'est rencontrés s'annoncer paléo en
2009 et on a pu boucler la boucle en
2014 en fêtant les 40 ans de ce festival
les deux sur scène avec énormément de
monde parce que pour le coup sur la
grande scène il fallait amener amené
beaucoup de force créative et ça a été
le cas et c'était une très belle manière
de boucler la boucle
merci beaucoup à un mouvement de faire
ça d'être sur les planches
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]